Київ-одне з найзеленіших міст Європи.
Такою побачив столицю України в 2012 році
німецький інженер з Кельна Дітмар Пейч.
Він переїхав до своєї дружини Людмили в Україну.
Щоб уберегти міську природу, незабаром
чоловіку довелося приєднатися до активістів
громадської організації "Екопарк Осокорки":
прибирати сміття біля водойм, брати участь
в акціях протесту і навіть уперше в житті відчути
дію сльозогінного газу поліцейських.
Все це, аби зупинити будівництво
понад сотні багатоповерхівок ось тут,
на лівому березі Дніпра, на місцині,  яку вчені
називають залишками первинних заплавних лук.
Або ми збережемо природу і переконаємо
міську владу, щоб вона цього не робила,
або Київ стане таким, як і багато інших
великих міст, - бетонною пустелею.
Активісти " Екопарку  Осокорки " вже три роки
чергують біля цього будмайданчика, через який тут
уже знищено сотні дерев, змінений рельєф дна та берегу водойми.
Люди вимагають від влади скасувати
дозвіл на будівництво і надати цій території захисний статус.
- Це виключно воля міської влади…
Якщо вона знайде політичну волю, вона може
своїм рішенням створити парк навколо озер і далі туди в бік луків.
Екологічні акції протесту в Києві не вщухають.
Забудовники шаленими темпами знищують
зелені насадження в різних районах столиці.
У КМДА заспокоюють. Мовляв, забудовники,
якщо й вирубали дерева, то платять місту
за висадку нових, у мегаполісі постійно проводяться
роботи з озеленення і є понад 300 парків та скверів
І взагалі, Київ зі своїми майже сорока тисячами гектарів
зелених насаджень - не найменш зелене місто Європи.
Це такі собі ігри зі статистикою, вважають
у міжнародній організації "Екологія. Право. Людина".
Реальність геть інша. Зелених насаджень багато
лише в лісах на околицях Києва. В місті ж вони
зникають катастрофічними темпами.
- "Київзеленбуду" потрібно зберігати і доглядати
зелені насадження. Але тим часом
Київська міська рада за останні 20 років
видала багато рішень, щоб ці ж самі парки
відвести під забудову.
За різними даними, таким чином у Києві
за 20 років знищили близько мільйона дерев.
У "Київзеленбуді" кажуть, що роблять усе можливе,
аби зберегти підконтрольні їм зелені зони.
- У минулому році було видалено
сухостійних і аварійних дерев біля 8000,
а висаджено 13 000 дерев.
Така ж ситуація - в лісопарках господарства.
Ми висадили за 20 років 20 млн дерев.
Часто ці висадки хаотичні, непродумані,
а в парках, скверах і на вулицях з’являються
інвазійні породи дерев, тобто такі,
як от цей червоний дуб, здатний до експансії.
Із часом він може витіснити дерева навколо.
Екологиня Катерина Полянська закликає владу
до застосування наукового підходу до озеленення Києва.
У " Київзеленбуді " теж визнають, що лише
їхніх зусиль задля збереження Києва зеленим
уже давно недостатньо. Потрібна загальноміська
програма озеленення та координація усіх
комунальних служб столиці, аби врятувати хоча б те, що є.
Приміром, от ці каштани на Хрещатику, які
повільно вмирають через велику кількість солі,
яку розкидають на тротуари взимку комунальники,
а потім згрібають усе під дерева.